So welcome to this session, which is entitled The
Dharma Master Yantai Advances in Targeted Therapy, and it
focuses on immunotherapy and DNA repair.
I'd like to read a statement on behalf of
AACR.
So Dharma Master Yantai, for whom this session is named, was a
brave young abbess who dedicated her life to Dharma teaching.
She was a never smoker who was diagnosed with lung cancer.
Although not available to her at the time, targeted treatments are now
available for the mutation that was identified in
Dharma Yantai's cancer.
According to her wishes and in memory of her, family
established an endowment to support the Dharma Master Yantai Advances in
Lung Cancer session.
This family's goal is to foster cancer research that leads to
new drugs development so that patients with cancer will live longer,
have better quality of life, and potentially reach a cure in
selected cases. So this was the citation that this
session is dedicated to.
With that, I'd like to kick off this
session. There will be three speakers, including myself,
and we will be focusing on the concept that
when a diagnosis is made, we typically react
based on the diagnosis. The idea that
instead one can possibly change the diagnosis
in favor of a better therapeutic outcome
is pretty novel, and we will hear from the speakers
several ways in which this potentially is possible or will
become possible,
including triggering cells to generate more
neoantigens.
And with that, it is my great pleasure to introduce the first speaker, that is
Yardena Samuels.
Hello, everybody, and welcome to the session.
So indeed, I'll be talking about revisiting the
neoantigen approach to cancer immunotherapy.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So it's well known that intratumor heterogeneity will determine
how aggressive the tumor will be and how well it will
respond to immunotherapy. And in fact, rather than thinking
of intratumor heterogeneity as an additional hallmark of cancer,
we actually think that it may be
overlaid onto all the hallmarks of cancer.
And this is a review that just came out
in the special cell issue celebrating 25 years since the
hallmarks of cancer,
which was just published. And actually, Alberto
co-published this with us as well, and so you're welcome to read more about our
thoughts about this. But then when you start defining what
intratumor heterogeneity actually is,
you can determine it on many different levels: on the genetic
level, the transcriptomic, epigenomic level, the proteomic
level. All these three, the genetic,
transcriptomic, and proteomic levels, will impact the
immunopeptidome level, which is basically the landscape of
neopeptides that are being presented on the tumor.
And this immunopeptidome repertoire will shape how the immune system
responds to the tumor. So you can think of the immunopeptidome as
an additional definition of intratumor heterogeneity.
Of course, intratumor heterogeneity is seen on the secretome, the drug
sensitivity level, as well as the tumor
microenvironment, which ultimately impacts the tumor
state. But today I'll be exploring the immunopeptidome,
and its level of heterogeneity. So we can think
of the immunopeptidome heterogeneity on two levels.
One is on the single cell level,
but also across different cells within the tumor.
Of course, we don't have single-cell immunopeptidomics at this point, and so
the first level is pretty hard to determine.
But identifying these neopeptides is of course extremely
important because we have several different modalities that you
can then use in order to treat
the tumors, whether it's mRNA vaccines, TCR cognate,
TCR T therapy, et cetera.
Now, despite these neopeptides being extremely useful, there are several
challenges in effectively targeting them.
And so I will discuss some of these and ways that we think
that we can solve these challenges.
So first is that most neoantigens derive from passenger mutations, and so
they're not recurrent across patients.
The second is that few of them are effectively presented on MHC
molecules. Third, neoantigens are often subclonal,
and so they're easy targets for immunoevasion.
And finally, especially in low TMB tumors, you will
not have sufficient neoantigens, and that is
most the focus of my talk. So regarding challenge number one,
what our solution to the fact that most neoantigens are
passenger-derived is that we have a data-driven approach to identify
recurrently presented neoantigens, which basically means that we look at
databases, identify recurrent somatic mutations,
and then look at what HLA allotypes these exact same patients
harbor, and only then we predict which neoantigens are going to be
presented specifically for the HLA allotypes that are harbored
by the patients who have this somatic mutation.
And then we rank these lists, and we only focus on the ones that have
potentially a high affinity of binding and are frequent within the
population.
We've done this quite a bit. At this point, we have a very large number of
recurrent neopeptides that we've identified.
We've proven them to be immunogenic.
For most of them, we have cognate T cell receptors, and so these are relevant
for about 350,000 patients
yearly.Challenge number two is that few neoantigens are
effectively presented by and targeted by the
TCRs. So we have a few platforms in the lab in order to
increase their presentation,
and one of them, actually, I'm showing you here that was effective, which is that
chemotherapy can enhance neoantigen-specific
TCR-mediated killing. What we did here is we focused on
KRAS G12V neoantigen, which we identified to be
presented, and we also have our own cognate TCRs.
And when we combine it with lymphodepleting
chemotherapy, which is usually given when there's CAR
T or TCR T therapy, you see that there's a synergy between
the two. And actually, the mechanism behind it is that there's an
increased presentation of the targeted neoantigen.
And this is true across neoantigens.
We've seen this for numerous ones, and we've seen this to be relevant also for
bispecific antibodies.
Challenge number three, neoantigens are often subclonal,
making them ineffective targets.
So our solution is to reduce intratumor heterogeneity
and applying a selective pressure to enrich the clonal
neoantigens that are derived from drug-resistant
mutations. And so we went about to
derive this SpotNeoMet tool together with Nuria
Lopez-Bigas,
which basically takes data from TCGA for primary tumors,
compares them to the Hartwig data for metastatic tumors,
and we run our pipeline to identify recurrent mutations.
We filter all the variants, predict which ones of them are going to be
drivers, and then predict what peptides may be
presented. And so you get quite a few targets, and
really you can see here the targets that are specific for the
metastatic cases, which are patients who received
these drugs. And so these are the ones that we're actually interested in.
And you can see here in a table format some well-known
genes and mutations that are derived
from drug treatments and lead to resistance.
You can also notice that they're all clonal.
And so we decided to focus on just this, but we're now working on all the others.
But this is the androgen receptor.
We proved it to be indeed presented.
It's immunogenic, and we now have three cognate T cell receptors
towards this target. And here
you see an ACT, an adoptive cell therapy treatment with one of
these TCRs effectively rejecting a
tumor that's presenting this neoantigen.
And so that is our solution, or at least one of the solutions for sub
clonality.
Challenge number four is the lack of identifying
neoantigens. So again, low TMB. So we need to
expand the pool of targetable neoantigens, and we need to
consider that cancer-specific
processes will derive cancer-specific
neoantigens. This is reflected on the
immunopeptidome. So we can actually take advantage of the hallmarks
of cancer that may lead to the presentation of
cancer-unique repertoires of peptides.
This is beyond the well-known classical somatic mutation-derived
neopeptides. And so we started off by looking at bacterial antigens,
because we know that bacteria populate tumors.
And so with Oved Strassman and Jennifer Wargo, we
sequenced 16S RNA sequencing to
identify the microbiome in numerous metastatic
melanoma samples, and then performed immunopeptidomics
on these samples and basically analyzed the data a bit differently.
We added the protein sequences of the identified
bacteria into the database and
then checked whether any of the masses of the peptides that we identified by
immunopeptidomics aligns to bacterial
sequences. And indeed, to our surprise, quite a few
HLA class I and HLA class II-derived peptides were identified, and
quite a few of them were immunogenic.
So this is one way to enlarge the antigenic space, even though we've still
not proven that these are cancer specific.
Another set of hallmarks is that there's
dysregulation of the translation fidelity components in
cancer. And this is especially true when there's a
stress response within the cells.
And so we decided to look into this,
specifically by looking at high interferon gamma levels
as a stress response. So interferon gamma derived from infiltrating
T cells will activate either one.
Either one will deplete tryptophan forming kynurenine, which will
inhibit T cell function. But the other side of the
coin is that when there's tryptophan being depleted, it will lead to uncharged
tRNAs, which reduces translation.
But the surprising part is that these ribosomes are now
paused on tryptophan residues. And despite the fact that there's
no tryptophan in the cell, these ribosomes will frame shift either
minus one or plus one, leading to aberrant peptide
presentation, quite a few of which are actually immunogenic.
And we did this together with Oved Nirg 化 mi's lab, and this is really a prime
example for non-mutational peptide antigens that
trigger an immune response.
Now, we know that other stresses will probably do the same.
For example, hypoxia, other cytokines, nutrient
deprivation will lead to changes in the tRNA pool and the
whole machinery leading to translation adaptation and again, altered
proteins and aberrant peptide presentation, increased
immunogenicity. But we also need to consider that intrinsic
drivers may do the same. And when I say intrinsic drivers,
these could be alterations in the translation machinery,
even on the genetic basis, again, leading to
translation adaptation and aberrant peptide
presentation.So in fact, compared to
a somatic mutation that will directly lead to a
neopeptide to be presented, in this case, if there's an
alteration in a translation fidelity factor, it will
amplify the number of aberrant proteins that are found and the number
of aberrant peptides that will be presented,
therefore increasing tumor immunogenicity.
This was our hypothesis.
So we decided to exploit the translation infidelity to expand the
targetable antigenic space, and we chose one
factor called TYW2 as a proof of concept.
Now, what TYW2 does, it adds a
Y-butysin moiety onto tRNA
phenylalanine on position 37, which is just next to the
anticodon loop. And when it adds that Y-butysin, it
stabilizes the ribosomes during translation and prevents them from
slipping. And so the idea is that if we knock out
TYW2,
you'll get hypomodified tRNA phenylalanine.
The ribosomes will slip, there will be aberrant protein
synthesis, aberrant peptide presentation, ultimately
leading to enhanced antitumor activity.
So this was our working plan, and we
stepped through all of these
steps, and I'll show you some of the data.
So the first thing we did was to knock out TYW2 from human
melanoma cell lines, and we used this reporter system from
Tachi Pilpel's lab that harbors a slippery sequence
that's derived from HIV gag-pol with two
fluorescent tags. And when we add this reporter system into our
knockout cells, we can clearly see that there's a frame shift right
here. And by producing this particular product, the
larger product, the minus one product.
And this can be rescued if you put back wild type TYW2,
then you get again the shorter product, and this shifts back.
So on the reporter system, it's looking good.
But we wanted to see what happens endogenously.
So for this, we looked for out-of-frame peptides.
So we took our three TYW2 knockout
clones and performed immunopeptidomics on them and compared
the peptide sequences to the wild type.
And you can clearly see a very nice cluster here of
out-of-frame peptides, which is a much larger number than you
would ever see for the classical neoantigens.
And you know this is not chaotic. This is actually programmed because you can
see that you have recurrent peptides that occur
throughout these different clones.
So
this is clearly
well-defined, and it's a programmed process.
But we wanted to actually search for the proxy Phe peptides, the ones
that really occur on that slippery sequence inside of the human
cells. Now, very little is known about slippery sequences in
mammalian cells. Most of the information we have today is about
viruses. So we needed to perform Ribo-seq in order
to really understand the mechanism of this slippage.
And when we performed this ribosome profiling, we could see that there's a
pausing that occurs specifically on the phenylalanine
codons, both of them, when the ribosome
A-site is found on the codon. You can see it right here.
And so what this actually means is that if in the literature
we knew that when there's no Y butysin and there's slippage, there's
a minus one effect, this allowed us to understand that there could also be a
plus one effect. And we found out that
when the slippage occurs, it could either incorporate the
phenylalanine or not. Now, the reason we obsess about
understanding this mechanism is because without it, you cannot
analyze the immunopeptidomic data in a very accurate way.
Because now that we know the biology, we can include it into our
databases. And indeed, when we incorporated this
information, we got this nice list of aberrant peptides,
most of which were of a plus one frame shift, and quite a few of
them were chimeric, which means that they had a stretch of
in-frame and then an out-of-frame sequence,
which suggests that this is going to be highly immunogenic because it's
non-self.
Now, with these error-prone sequences
in hand, as well as these dark peptides, you can start
mechanistically exploring the biogenesis of these dark
proteins. What do I mean by that? We can now make these
reporters and include these error-prone sequences.
Rather than using an HIV gag-pol sequence, we can now
use the ones that we identified within these human cells.
And we can now, we in collaboration, Marina Rodina actually
did this.
It's a very, very unique system where you do a
reconstitution of translation in vitro, and
all of its components are basically isolated from the
cells, including the tRNAs. So we can now
use our isogenic wild type and knockout cells,
isolate these components, including the phenylalanine tRNA,
and check them on this reporter. And you can get the
resolution of seconds. It's very accurate, and it's very
quantitative. And so this is the data that we have.
So you see we have here either a hypomodified
tRNA or a modified tRNA, and we have the reporter
system with a slippery sequence of the phenylalanine codon.
If it's a zero frame, okay, if there's no slippage, you would
expect this product to be formed. But if there is
slippage, you'll get a shorter product.
So above you see the situation that you get when you use a
modified tRNA. So the wild type, you see the larger
product. But when you use the hypomodified tRNA, you
start seeing very early on this smaller product
showing that indeed there is a frame shift.
So this is the ultimate proof that indeed we identified a
particular sequence that is slippery.
So like I said, this is a programmed rather than a chaotic
process.So of course, we expected these to be immunogenic,
and so this is an immunogenicity assay that we do in the lab using healthy donor
blood. And
we can clearly see here that the ones that we
tested are highly immunogenic, but the main question is,
are these aberrant peptides mediating an immune response in vivo?
And so to check this, we knocked out TYW2 in murine cells,
and you can see that we injected them into immunocompetent mice that very
clearly rejected compared to the wild type cells.
This is reversed if you then rescue with a wild type
TYW2, and if you do this in immunocompromised
mice, they all grow similarly. And if you deplete CD8 positive T
cells, you revert the phenotype. So the rejection is due to CD8
positive T cells.
We then wanted to find out which aberrant peptides are leading to this
rejection. So we isolated bone marrow-derived dendritic
cells and loaded them with T cell lysates, sorry,
with
lysates derived from either the wild type or the knockout cells.
First of all, checked what happens if you co-incubate them with splenic CD8
positive T cells. You can clearly see that the
knockout-derived dendritic cells are
inducing much more proliferation of the T cells compared to the wild type.
And then we performed immunopeptidomics, and we saw that there was a similar
number of canonical peptides, but the proxiph
peptides, there was a clear difference between the wild type and the
knockout cells. So we can now use these
peptides to start assessing immunogenicity.
How am I doing with time?
Three minutes? Okay. So I'll go really quickly.
So we basically showed that indeed these peptides are highly
immunogenic also in mice. We saw that
at day 21, you get an increase CD8 positive T
cells into these tumors.
And when that happens, you get an increased exhaustion
of these T cells. So you see an increased PD-1, CTLA-4, and
LAG-3. And so we redid the experiment where we injected the
knockout and wild type cells, but in this case, we actually treated with
anti-PD-1. And you can see that the anti-PD-1 does not work on
the wild type cells at all. Whereas if you use the
anti-PD-1 on the TYW2 knockout cells, you get this
flat line. And actually, even at 50 days, only
40% of the mice developed tumors. And so
this is the ultimate experiment where we were able to
inject our wild type and knockout cells into immunocompetent
mice,
treat with anti-PD-1, and now check the
immunogenicity of these,
well, by co-incubating with T cells, the splenic T cells, and
co-culturing with peptide pulse DCs, we could check for immunogenicity.
And you can clearly see that the aberrant
peptides that we identified to be presented are inducing
high interferon gamma release from these T cells, as well as
increased proliferation. So this really shows that the endogenous presentation of
the aberrant peptides is sufficient to trigger a de novo
antigen-specific T cell response in
these mice.
Patient data corroborates this, so low
TYW2 is correlated
with better response to immune checkpoint blockade.
This is independent to tumor mutational burden, and in fact,
the significant correlation remains also in low TMB
patients. So TYW2 is also a biomarker.
This is now looking at additional cancer types.
We see that there's a high level expression of TYW2 in quite a
few cancer types, and so potentially it could be targeted in
various cancers. We checked this.
We checked this in colorectal cancer and breast cancers, and indeed, the
reporter assays show that also there you get a
frame-shifting effect on the reporters.
And of course, if we want to inhibit it, TYW2, in
order to increase immunogenicity, everyone worried about toxicity and induction
of autoimmunity. And so to relieve that worry, we now
have TYW2 knockout mice, and they're
non-pathological on all the different tests.
And so really, we want to enhance neoantigen
presentation and even beyond what we've already seen.
So we're now looking at many additional factors that are in the
translation machinery. You can see some of them here.
So we just concluded an in vivo CRISPR screen, and we're
now following up on several new factors.
And the additional way to increase neoantigen presentation is
not only silencing translation fidelity regulators, it's actually
also silencing the protein and the RNA quality
control system. So we've heard about NMD, for example.
So we have additional ways to increase even further
neoantigen presentation, and this is an additional direction that we're working on.
So at this point, I'd like to thank this amazing group of people
who've done lots and lots of work, as well as the many
collaborators that helped us get this done. Thank you.
Thank you. Oops. Thank you, Yardenna.
There is time for two or three questions, if there are
any. Yeah, please go ahead.
Hi. Thank you for that great talk. My name's Nicolette. I'm from BC Cancer.
I have a question about whether we should be considering HLA
loss of heterozygosity,
when we're predicting clonal neoantigens
So really that first half of your talk.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, for sure. So it means that once
the HLA is lost, then we will not be able to target those
neoantigens. So targeting them early on or
targeting quite a few of them in parallel right before that actually
happens,
would be a clever way to go about that. Right?
So of course, that is an additional biomarker that we take into account.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
Over there.
Hello. Thank you very much. I was wondering if in your screen you see any
evidence for the RNA methylation pathways to be important, and if
they could also be targeted to induce new antigens.
No.
That's a really good question. It's an additional screen to be done.
I'm pretty sure we did not include them in this particular screen, but yes.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
One of the limitations you mentioned was neoantigen heterogeneity.
Doesn't the inhibition of translation fidelity increase heterogeneity?
Yeah. That's a great question. Yeah.
I actually think that it increases clonality because
this is not a chaotic system. This is a very programmed system,
and so I think the results we're getting are so dramatic and
impressive, not only because we're amplifying neoantigens, we're also
increasing clonality on the level of the immunopeptidome landscape, and we're now
working on proving that.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Thank you, Yardena. Thank you for the great talk.
All right, so we move on, and it's now my turn to present.
And
today I'll discuss with you inhibition of DNA mismatch
repair for therapeutic purposes.
These are my disclosure, one of which is relevant and is linked
to being a founder of Neophore.
So we are alive because
evolution has developed and nearly perfected a mechanism
that
preserve
fidelity across replication. And you can see this
in this staggering number,
when we are born, and then we develop, our cells divide and, of
course,
by the age of 50, we will have
had many cell divisions in somatic cells and these would have undergone
through a
staggering number of nucleotides that are present in our genome.
So it is remarkable and always good to remember how
important it is, DNA repair.
I'll talk about today a specific form of DNA repair, mismatch repair, that I'm
sure you're aware of, and that has also evolved through
evolution, but essentially has remained the same.
So bacteria and mammalian cells work and operate in a very similar
way, whereby the component of this machinery
recognize and fix post-replicative DNA error.
You're also aware that, and we will hear more from Luis Diaz in the
next presentation, that when this occurs pathologically,
a number of genes can be altered, and as a result, tumor progression can
occur.
But if mismatch repair is
disabled, then what happens concomitantly is that you will get high
tumor mutational burden, you will get microsatellite instability,
and you will get high number of neoantigens.
And as a result,
cells that develop such a phenotype will be potentially
recognizable by the immune system, and
mismatch repair deficient tumors are among the best
responders to immunotherapy, and I'm sure we will hear more about
this later. With this in mind, a number of
years ago, my lab embarked into a campaign that would
consider, for the first time, disabling mismatch repair
on purpose in cells that are otherwise mismatch repair
proficient.
And I'll present to you a few vignettes on how we have done this, the results we
have obtained, and in the end, also the latest results
regarding blocking PMS2 with a small molecule.
So the story really started by the work of a postdoc,
now an associate professor at the University of Milano, that is
Giovanni. Giovanni decided to target MLH1,
disable MLH1
with a knockout in mouse colorectal and other cell lines.
And what he was able to show by doing so is that the cells that were
regenerated were largely unable to form tumors in genetic
animals, as you can see here,
and that the tumors that form were infiltrated
by T cells and other cells, and that
by blocking T cells specifically, and in this case CD8 T cells,
the phenotype could be reverted.
So we thought we had a model that we could study, and because the cells, as
I mentioned, are largely immunogenic, we have to grow them
first in immunodeficient animal, transplant them into an
immunocompetent animal, and then if we want to study immunotherapy, we can do
that efficiently at this point because these tumors become very, very
responsive to immune checkpoint blockade.
To a point that I've never seen before, and that was really promising and
exciting for us.
The other observation that we made together with the pathologists over a number of
years now is that even in mismatch repair proficient tumors,
you will
often find areas that are mismatch repair deficient.
What I mean is that there will be glands, sometimes entire regions
that are mismatch repair deficient.
The reason for that to occur is still unclear,
but it's very interesting. If we extract DNA from these
regions, from these cells, and we subject it to profiling,
this is bona fide mismatch repair deficient
cells with high MSI, high tumor mutational
burden.So this brought about an idea that
perhaps we can then consider teasing out these cells for
therapeutic purposes. And in order to do that, the first question we had to address
was whether and what was the minimal number of mismatch repair deficient
cells, MSI high cell, in an otherwise mismatch repair proficient
tumor for the phenotype to occur. And you can see here that we have
mixed different fraction of proficient and deficient cells.
And if we do that in immunodeficient animal, now we don't see much.
But if we do that in immunocompetent animal, we can go
sometimes up to 20% of the cells being
deficient for the tumor to be recognized fully by the immune system.
So energized by this, we went forward with this approach, and
we started to consider the possibility that we would use
drugs already available to tease out mismatch repair deficient cells.
The idea came from an experiment that I did many years ago, you can
tell that by the aging of my face,
in Bert's lab. And you can also tell the timing because we had pagers
back then and not cell phones. So this is a really prehistoric
concept. And if you don't know, myself, Yadena, and Luis trained in the
same lab, so they probably recognize this hood. Anyway.
So, back then, one project that we started
was to see whether we could identify carcinogens that would induce
specific forms of genetic instability.
And in doing so, I realized, and later used for
the project I'm going to describe, that some of them could be very useful
because they select for mismatch repair deficient cells.
So these are methylating agents, and two forms of these agents, temozolomide
and 6-thioguanine,
are used in therapy. And so we become excited by the possibility that
we would replicate what we had seen many years ago,
for therapeutic purposes.
And to do that, the first thing we had to do is to
confirm that these agents, in this case, we have used
6-thioguanine, could be useful in vivo.
And so you can see here that we have replicated the experiments that I showed you
before by mixing different fraction of proficient and
deficient cells. And then we have teased out from these
fractions the mismatch repair deficient cells with 6-thioguanine.
And if you do that in vivo, you will see that the tumor prominently respond and
that this phenotype is dependent on the immune system.
So that was exciting for us and suggested that maybe we should take
this to the clinic. And so, Silvia Marsoni in our
group devised a clinical trial, which is called ARETUSA, that was
performed in the last few years in Italy and Spain.
And you can see here that the concept was that we would use MGMT
methylating colorectal cancer for priming with
temozolomide. In this case, we
used temozolomide, and then we would measure
level of mutational burden and MSI status in
biopsies with blood or tissue biopsy.
And if the tumor had increased mutational burden, we would then go with Pembro.
The results are
in part published and in part being published still.
But you can see here that some of the
patients, some of their tumors really increased prominently the
level of mutations as a result of exposure
to temozolomide.
You're probably asking what happens to the treatment, and the result of the
trial were, in fact, negative, broadly speaking, because the
endpoint was not met. But some of the patients did have a prolonged response
after increased mutational burden achieved through temozolomide exposure.
So this is a proof of concept that this can be done clinically and was
suggestive that maybe we could develop this further.
So how can we go beyond ARETUSA? And that involved
thinking inside the lab and further refining the concept.
And so Pietro Paolo Vitiello, a physician scientist in my group, started to
combine different chemotherapeutic agents to see which one
of them would increase mutational burden and possibly lead
to mismatch repair deficiency.
And doing that and performing the screening, we stumble on a combination that
involves cisplatin temozolomide. You can see here the results.
If we do that, the cells acquire a high level of
mutational burden. The number of predicted neoantigens increase.
And of course, we also get signatures which are related to alkylating agents.
So that was promising. Took it one step forward preclinically.
And what we have found, and depending on whether we inject in immunodeficient or
immunocompetent, we have learned that this is the assay we often use.
You can see that the cells that are treated are slightly delayed or
sometimes, as in this case, when we use a competent immune
system,
rejected or under strong control.
All right. So far, what I tried to convince you is that perhaps we
can use cytotoxic agents to select for mismatch repair deficient cells.
However, this approach is
affected by toxicity and limitation in the response of the immune
system.
And so we wanted to move forward with a different strategy.
And that led to the concept that maybe for the first time, we
wanted to disable pharmacologically mismatch repair.
Of course, you're probably thinking that this will be a high-risk project, and
indeed it is. In order to achieve that, there was no available drug, and we
had to start from scratch.
We consider targeting a specific molecule, in this case, PMS2.
I don't have time to get into the details as to why we selected PMS2.
But a campaign was started to block PMS2.
But some concept before we move forward.
I told you before that mismatch repair deficiency occurs in cancer, and you're
probably very familiar with two forms of this deficiency.
Lynch syndrome, which is a germline syndrome in which one of the two
allele is disabled, and then sporadic mismatch repair deficiency, which is what
I've been talking about so far.However, there is a third form
of this genetic alteration, which occurs
rarely in individuals that will have no copies
of a functional mismatch repair gene.
This is called constitutional mismatch repair deficiency.
And if you consider somatically what happens to this individual, you will
see that this occurs because of, as I said, biallelic
germline loss of the mismatch repair gene.
In most cases, it is PMS2, but surprisingly
perhaps, these individuals will reach adulthood.
This is because DNA repair, mismatch repair is only required
in some conditions, and somatic cells
can live without mismatch repair, as proven by this individual.
Of course, it is not without risk, and this individual will develop tumors,
but they reach adulthood, and many of the tissues are normal.
In fact, these individuals are now treated very effectively with
immunocheckpoint blockade, and there are reports that even in some instances,
high-grade gliomas can be treated in these patients effectively.
So with this in mind, we embark on a campaign to target PMS2.
This was done in collaboration with Neophore, and the chemists that developed
these inhibitors are in this room today, so if you have any questions...
I didn't do very well in chemistry, so it's better if you ask them.
But I'll describe the concept and the findings that
occur. So this was a seven-year effort that led to the
development of a molecule, which is called 1867,
and this molecule was developed from this fragment hit,
and I don't have time to describe all this campaign, but suffice it to say that the
molecule is non-toxic. You can see this on the left-hand side.
And the molecule is specific for the ATPase of
PMS2 as it binds to a cysteine, that is cysteine 73, that is
located in the ATPase of PMS2. A
control molecule was also developed, is this molecule below here.
The molecule is inactive because it doesn't have the same characteristic in
terms of binding, but otherwise serves as a perfect chemical control for all the
next experiment. If you're interested more in our work, it's being presented
today and published today in Cancer Discovery through the mechanisms that
Cancer Discovery and other AACR journals have developed of co-publication.
So a little bit more on this molecule and its specificity and selectivity.
So this molecule targets PMS2 in a cell-based cysteinome and ATPase
profiling. You can see here the specificity.
There are hundreds of ATPases here, and you can see the specificity of the
molecule. I already mentioned that it will bind to a specific cysteine,
cysteine 73, and in this plot you can see that the specificity is very
high and is very selective, this molecule, because there
are 20,000 or more cysteines in the cysteinome and
no other cysteine is targeted.
So you're probably asking whether the phenotype that we
achieve with the molecule is similar to the genotype that is generated by
disabling genetically a mismatch repair.
So here what we measure is a challenge to the cell with 60
guanine again. So 60 guanine will generate nicks into the DNA.
These are measured in the y-axis, and you can see that if we do that in wild-type
cells, this alteration in the DNA will
accumulate. However, if we disable genetically PMS2 in these
cells, this does not occur, suggesting that we
have abrogated completely the mismatch repair
catalytic activity.
What is fascinating here is that the molecule recapitulates
perfectly what we do genetically, and depending on the concentration of the
molecule, you will achieve abrogation of the
phenotype that parallels exactly the one that is achieved genetically.
So this is a very successful campaign so far.
The other thing that we did and that Neophore did was to develop an assay
to monitor the target
engagement. And this happened in the lab by the work of Eleanor
Piumatti, a PhD student in my group, that one day came to me and said, "Alberto,
when I treat with PMS2 but not with the control molecule, I see a band
shift." And that band shift became our assay for
target engagement, and Neophore perfected this using mass spectrometry.
You can see here that we can measure target engagement
very carefully and very accurately, and this is useful also for in vivo studies.
What happens if we dose cells for a long time or different time with the
molecule? The molecule affects the cells.
It's not cytotoxic, I mentioned this already, but it will slowly
generate a transition from mismatch repair proficiency to deficiency.
You can see this as measured in a number of
mutations per megabase. You can see this measured in the MSI score that
increases, and the MSI score ultimately becomes equivalent to that
of a tumor that a pathologist would classify as MSI.
Another way of measuring the impact of the molecule on the cells is
transitioning to
a new mutational signature, which is the one associated to mismatch repair
deficiency. And you can see here SBS21 and SBS15
appearing in cells that are treated with the molecule, and this does not
occur with the control molecule. And again, suggesting and indicating that
we have converted these cells into MSI and high mutational
burden.
What happens if we go in vivo with these cells?
So if we do that, and this is the evidence, the cells that are
treated in vitro transplanted in immunocompetent animals are under
control if the immune system is triggered by a checkpoint blockade
inhibitor, and it's shown here. And obviously, control
suggests that this doesn't occur if the cells are not treated with the compound.
We are also accumulating data on the impact of the
compound on the immunological profile of the tumors, and you can see here the
initial data.
We have many more results. I'd like to highlight that this molecule at this stage
can be used in vitro,
doesn't have yet the property of pharmacodynamic and pharmacokinetic
property to be used in vivo. Although the company has made in recent months very
high progress in generating an oral version of this
molecule.We did this also in a second model.
Of course, it's always important, especially if you want to publish in a
high-profile journal, to do this in multiple models.
So we did this in an orthotopic breast cancer model.
So the results are the same, possibly even better than in colorectal cancer cells,
and it takes slightly less for these cells to convert into immunologically
sensitive.
Still facing many issues, and in order to go to the clinic, which we want to do
as soon as possible, we need to achieve a faster transition to
the mismatch repair deficient state, and we want to also be able
to dose the compound with chemotherapy.
So the latest results, which are unpublished, not part of the paper, are a
campaign that we started based on the knowledge that we had developed before to
see whether combining 1867, so the PMS2 inhibitor with
chemotherapy would induce a faster transition.
And the results are really exciting, and so we have tried several combinations,
including approved combination that are used in colorectal cancer, such as
FOLFOXIRI. And if we use combination of FOLFOXIRI and
1867, specifically the other molecules are not doing the
same impact, you can see that the transition is much faster into the
MSI status high tumor mutational burden, and you can also see a very nice
rejection, sometimes not even needing the exposure to any
immune checkpoint blockade.
So in conclusion,
I think I've convinced you, or I tried to convince you that
genetic inactivation of mismatch repair can be
phenocopied
for therapeutic purposes with molecules, that these molecules can be developed,
that these molecules are not toxic for the cells, and that they
will lead progressively to a high tumor mutational burden and a
high MSI score.
And that in the future, it will be very relevant to combine this molecule together
with chemotherapeutic agents in order to achieve high-level efficacy,
and that's exactly where we're going.
I'd like to thank
the founders of this work and the grant support that I received,
that are listed here, Knyohfor that I already mentioned, all the people that were
involved, including my team, the team of the clinicians that did a lot
of the clinical studies that I mentioned, including the ARETUSA study,
and the team at Knyohfor that is listed here.
With that, I'll close and take any question if there are any. Thank you very much.
It's a really great talk. Thank you so much. Exciting work.
Did you ever go back and look at the patients to understand why some
patients didn't generate a higher TMB
or convert to mismatch repair deficient status?
Was there potential drivers in that case?
Yeah. It's a good question. So in the ARETUSA, we went back
and the best correlation we could find is the number and the
timing of exposure to temozolomide.
So some patients could not tolerate temozolomide for multiple cycles.
Some patients did not respond to temozolomide, and those
patients had not transitioned to increased tumor mutational
burden or high level of neoantigens predicted.
So there is a good correlation between the two.
It's also important to highlight that in that trial,
the trial was paralleled by a trial that is called MAIA, that I encourage you to go
and look, which has better results, and instead of treating
first with temozolomide and then with immunotherapy, did a combination of the
two, possibly increasing the chances of the patients to respond.
So that's all I can elaborate.
Similar, in that same direction, the screen
that you did that initially identified temozolomide and cisplatin, was
that screen in one model, and do you think that different
genetic backgrounds, different transcriptomic backgrounds,
different chemotherapeutic combinations would potentiate mismatch
repair deficiency-
Yeah
... better?
Yeah, so that's a very important question and something they were working deeply.
So, we don't think that's
the best combination that we can find.
We're making progress on better combination.
It seems that you still need to use platinum salts,
the timing of the exposure is also relevant,
and of course, if we continue to do that, toxicity will be a
limiting aspect, so we are considering which one will be the option.
But
I think you should listen to Luis Diaz that I think will tell more about how to
use chemotherapy to induce neoantigens. Yeah.
Thank you for
it.
If I remember correctly, some of the temozolomide results when
patients were chronically treated, they became TMB high, but not
necessarily MSI high or DMMR.
Is there any mechanistic rationale why there was perhaps a disconnect?
And I'm wondering if you connect to this PMS2 inhibitor, are these
tumors that have been chronically treated with a PMS2 inhibitor in the priming
phase, are they really clones that are de novo DMMR, or are they
just
something a little bit different?
Yeah, so
we have not dosed a single patient yet with the PMS2, so I cannot comment
on that. But on the ARETUSA trial, I have a comment, and that's actually a
very important point. I didn't have time to get into this, but if you read the
paper, you will see that the transition to mismatch repair deficiency is also
highlighted by the appearance of a specific mutation in MSA6,
which is the same mutation that occurs in glioma.
Why these cells did not completely convert to mismatch repair deficiency,
I'm not sure. Obviously,
I again think that the timing of exposure there, it cannot be optimized.
There is only that much temozolomide that you can give and the patient can
tolerate, and it's not a very effective therapy.
It's just a proof of concept for me.
I'm not sure that that's the right way to go, but that you can change
the microenvironment, well, that's for sure.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Do you have any rationale for why these chemotherapy
agents are doing this?
You said platinum just now. I mean-
What is the reason why just random chemotherapy agents will
induce this state? And
obviously, chemotherapy is used in combination with
immunotherapy in, say, gastric cancer.
Could that be occurring in gastric cancer or elsewhere?
Yeah. Well,
like I said, the reason to develop a PMS2 inhibitor was
precisely that. There is only that much that one can
do with currently available chemotherapeutic agents that have
inherent toxicity.
The reason why
cisplatin was working better than oxaliplatin
is still under investigation. But as I mentioned earlier, we have found that other
platinum cells are better at doing this.
And that may be relevant for how we develop the clinical trial.
So we are currently still investigating that.
Sorry, I cannot give you a better answer.
Yes?
Congratulations. Great talk, Alberto.
I was curious to know whether the inhibition of PMS2 in
metastatic models gives rise to such long-term remission of the
metastasis also, similarly to primary tumors.
Mm-hmm.
And second question, if you tried several monoclonal
antibodies directed against PD-1, PD-L1, CTL4, and
in case which one works best with PMS2 inhibitors? Thank you.
Yeah. So for the first question,
thank you for the question by the way, it can only be
addressed by the oral version of the molecule.
We cannot dose
for a long time effectively with the PMS2 inhibitor that we have, the
1867. But that is a super important question,
and determining which one is the clinical stage at which this will be particularly
effective remains relevant. Of course, when we move to the
clinic, as we greatly hope to do, this will be in a phase
one, and so obviously these will be metastatic patients.
How long we will need to dose and also remember, there is also
the opportunity that one could conjugate these compounds to,
these days ADC are making great progress.
I forgot the second question.
Yes. So we have tried so far only combination with
anti-CTL4. We haven't tried the other combination yet.
We didn't see much of a difference.
So we think that Pembro or the equivalent, an anti-PD-1
should be preferable, yeah. But we don't exclude the possibility to
combine. It hasn't been decided yet, from my understanding.
Two more question, then we need to move to the next speaker. Yeah.
Great work. I was just speculating on resistance mechanisms.
Obviously, not all MSI high tumors respond to checkpoint blockade,
certainly prostate cancers and other tumor types.
And I was wondering if you'd comment on redundancy
between the MMR proteins or other mechanisms that could drive
resistance, both in the de novo context, but also in this
artificially induced-
Yes. This is really relevant and whether
we should explore also
MSI-resistant populations already
existing with the compound.
I think we can test this now in vitro and in vivo because we can replicate
that model, and we are very excited by the possibility that another opportunity
would be not only to treat de novo MSS patients, but
also to include a category of patients that are MSI but
refractory to...
Because they may be primed. There are also evidences that there may be a biomarker
that we could use to select
tumors that are already prone to develop this phenotype, and we're working
with Neo4 to identify these tumors, suggesting that there may be
some subset of patients that are more prone to transition rapidly to the MSI
high status. But that's super interesting. Last question.
Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. I just wanted to ask if you've considered, using
other inhibition or knockdown of other mismatch repair enzymes to sort of
accelerate that process into mismatch repair deficiency or microsatellite
instability?
Yeah. So that's also a very good point.
So
the genetic work was done in parallel with PMS2, with MLH1,
MSH6, and MSH2. And the results,
especially for MLH1 and PMS2, were equivalent.
And so in principle, you would. Whether we will get an additional
benefit to block multiple, I don't think so,
but you're right that some of them may work as-- all of
them work as dimers, so you may want to.
But it seems that PMS2 from what we have, at the
beginning, there was a lot of work on focusing on which one was the most effective
one to target, at least initially. Yeah.
Thank you.
All right. With that, we'll close.
We need to move to the next speaker, that is Louis Diaz.
And so Louis, please, the floor is yours.
Thanks, Alberto, and thanks to everyone for staying this late into the meeting.
So I'll be speaking to something very similar to what Alberto did, which is
our idea of chemically engineering mismatch repair deficiency to induce tumor
immunogenicity. And it actually touches on a lot of
biological principles that we believe are true in general for immunogenicity.
And I'm very interested in the discussion afterwards. These are my disclosures.
So our current therapeutic paradigm, like Alberto said, is passive.
The patient walks in the door and either has, by chance, the
target we want or we don't want, and we treat it, and they may or may not respond.
But can we flip this around, where we can hack the tumor to create a
target
and then take that tumor, treat it with what we want to treat it, and induce a
therapeutic response? So really changing the therapeutic paradigm, rather than
by random chance having the patient walk through our door, create
the genotype/phenotype that we want to treat that patient.
And the model that we've focused on is mismatch repair deficiency.
You heard some of this from Alberto before.Very sensitive to immune checkpoint
blockade. This is a patient with metastatic colorectal cancer responding very
quickly with 20 weeks of PD-1 blockade.
And we think that this is largely because of a higher tumor mutational burden.
This is just a comparison in the number of mutations per mismatched
repair-deficient tumors in all other tumor types.
Early on in the early '90s, it was described that these tumors are highly
infiltrated with lymphocytes,
very rich in immune checkpoint overexpression,
both metabolic and protein expression on the surface.
And early studies by our group showed that immune checkpoint blockade in
colorectal cancer
induced a deep radiographic response
and a very good overall survival and progression-free
survival. This was shown to be tumor agnostic,
and overall survival was not reached in virtually every
group except pancreatic cancer and gliomas.
This led to the first tumor-agnostic approval.
We then went to early-stage disease and found that in early-stage disease
with rectal cancer, we could achieve complete responses in patients
very quickly with single-agent PD-1 blockade for six months.
This was the first patient. The next 13 patients all had a complete response.
So in the metastatic setting, highly effective.
In the locally advanced setting, it was highly effective and curative in this
setting. No need for surgery, radiation, or chemotherapy.
So obviously, a desire to reproduce this phenotype would
be very effective. Now, 95% of tumors,
regardless of where they are, are not mismatched repair deficient, so how can we
recreate that?
And one of the things was, well, why are these tumors responding?
We actually, to this day, have hypotheses as why they're responding, but we really
don't know. So one was tumor mutational burden.
And Benoit Roussel and Mike Foote started looking at this question,
and there was a lot of thought that tumor mutational burden alone drove all of
this. Expression of mutated proteins
would be expressed as neoantigens, and then they would induce a strong immune
response that was inhibited by PD-1.
You block PD-1 blockade, and you get a response.
But we were seeing a lot of patients in the clinic with high mutational burdens
that weren't responding. And so we took the Memorial data,
and in fact, when you look at high mutational burden, more than 10 mutations per
coding
exome, mutations per megabase,
they did better in terms of overall survival.
But then when we removed the mismatched repair deficient tumors and
the polymerase delta and epsilon deficient tumors, which were
known to be highly immunogenic from the mutational burden count,
tumor mutational burden then became no different than lower mutational burden,
so saying to us that the nature of the high TMB
mattered.
So then we could segregate tumors where the high TMB mattered
and where the high TMB didn't matter.
And there were TMB-sensitive tumors
and TMB-insensitive tumors. So the TMB-sensitive
tumors were non-small cell lung cancer, melanoma, and head-neck
cancer, and TMB-insensitive tumors were these other tumor
types here listed. And so what's common with all the
TMB-sensitive tumors?
They're all induced by exogenous or thought to be induced by
exogenous environmental antigens or environmental exposures.
Non-small cell lung cancer, head-neck, tobacco, melanoma, UV
light.
And so when we saw this data, we said, "Well,
maybe there's a way to induce this
pharmacologically in a way that would be immunogenic."
So we next look at mutation class, and one
concept that we looked at in the diagnostic arena
was that the more foreign
a DNA sequence, the easier it is to detect.
Your specificity is going to be better, performance is going to be better.
And if you take the most similar to
self, which are gene amplifications or deletions or point mutations, those are the
least foreign. The error rates are higher of those diagnostically.
And those that are most foreign, like gene rearrangements, indels, and frameshift
mutations, would be most foreign.
But what if you applied that to the foreignness of a potential
neoantigen?
And so what we did was we began looking at
using our reverse blast at the
dissimilarity between the native protein and the mutant
protein.
And the more dissimilar the collection of these
mutations,
the more foreign the tumor would look.
The more similar, the less foreign the tumor would look.
And we called these alien peptides because
we were actually blasting against all organisms known to man.
But
we've now recently changed that from alien to xeno, just to be a little bit more
politically correct.
But looking at these mutations and the foreignness of the tumor, not
surprising, the most foreign
tumors were mismatched repair deficient tumors, polymerase epsilon
and delta deficient tumors, non-small cell lung cancer, and renal cell carcinoma.
And when we began to categorize the mutations in terms of their foreignness,
not surprisingly, frameshift mutations, in-frame
indels, missense mutations, and splicing alterations were the
most foreign-derived peptides.
And so we knew a certain class of TMB was
immunogenic.
We knew that frameshift mutations and indels were highly
immunogenic in terms of foreignness.
What else did we know about this? We knew that in terms of the
evolution of immunogenicity in mismatched repair deficient
tumors is that it doesn't happen overnight.
If you knock out mismatched repair deficiency, you won't become immunogenic the
next day.
You won't have a high TMB the next day.
You won't have a high MSI score the next day.
And it takesNot weeks, but it takes months.
And it takes many months, closer to a year than six months.
So it's a slow process, and it's dependent on the division rate, because
you're creating spontaneous mutations and you're not correcting them.
And that happens over time. And then you're creating MSI
over time as well. And then that immunogenicity happens over time
as well. So in this case, we knocked out MSH2
in an MSS
cell line, and it took time for us to achieve a high
TMB, and it took time for us to develop MSI high and
immunogenicity responsive to PD-1 blockade.
So I'm not going to present all the data here, but we knew that what was
required for these patients to respond was loss of mismatch repair,
a high TMB, typically more than 20 mutations per megabase,
mutations enriched for indels, and specifically frame shift mutations,
so insertions and deletions where the loss or gain is not
divisible by three. I didn't touch upon this, it's slightly
controversial, but these tumors are highly diverse, and the mutations are all
subclonal.
The conventional wisdom in targeted therapy and
in immunotherapy is that these have to be clonal.
That's an argument we can have later, but these are highly subclonal.
Most of these neoantigens are subclonal.
And then finally, the immunogenicity takes time to develop.
So some of the principles that we have going forward.
And so the question was, could we pharmacologically recapitulate mismatch
repair deficiency in a mismatch repair proficient background?
And so could we do this chemically and alter the DNA for
desired genotype that would lead to immunogenicity?
And so there were two barriers, and before we got started with this project,
there was no lack of people who would say this would not work, because this is
going to lead to random immunogenesis, a subclonal architecture,
and would this still be immunogenic?
Because again, conventional wisdom and thinking now is you need something
clonal,
and that's what everyone's targeting.
And second is,
what about tumor viability
to immunogenications and systemic toxicity?
So two issues that we wanted to entertain.
The rationale for us was
that these tumors obviously were exquisitely sensitive to immune checkpoint
blockade, and we wanted to recapitulate that.
And could we begin to look for compounds that would
induce this phenotype that we wanted?
So I'll keep going forward here. So similar to what Alberto showed
and from a different path, we began to look at the mutational
signatures of a variety of different drugs that were
used for treating patients with cancer.
And there were two drugs that rose to the top of our list.
One was temozolomide. Temozolomide induces a high tumor
mutational burden. It's used in brain tumors.
Oftentimes you'll treat with a brain tumor, and you look at the
mutations before and after, and they induce thousands of mutations.
And the cisplatin was interesting because its mutational
signature was very specific for inducing insertions and deletions
and large frameshift mutations throughout the tumor.
And other agents that we were exploring were DMBA and ditranol,
and DMAA is a very interesting molecule because it's a component of
tobacco smoke.
And another one is ditranol, which is a component of tar.
And in our initial review of the induction of mutations and the
type of mutations, what we found is that these induced a high number of insertion
deletions.
So we did a variety of different analyses, and one was just
simply taking cells that were mismatch repair proficient, treating
them for eight weeks with a variety of different drugs.
I'll focus on temozolomide and cisplatin for this example.
Treat for eight weeks, wash them out for a week, so let them probably one or
two divisions there or passages. And then we looked at the genetic landscape, and
we did an immunogenicity assessment.
So this is the result with temozolomide and cisplatin, and we looked at cisplatin
alone and temozolomide alone. So no drug for eight weeks.
We get some mutations that shift, some TMB decrease, actually.
The MSI score is really not increased that much.
We get some more missense mutations and some more frame shift mutations.
With cisplatin alone, after eight weeks, we get a slight increase in TMB.
We get more missense mutations, more frame shift mutations.
But what you can see by the histogram is you get a clonal population.
So there's a shift there.
With temozolomide more, you actually achieve a much higher tumor
mutational burden. MSI score stays flat, more missense mutations, frame
shift mutations, largely subclonal, suggesting random mutagenesis.
But when we combine them,
and
I
keep talking to the postdoc in the lab, and now he's a faculty member, what was the
rationale for combining them? And we still don't know.
But when we combine them,
initially, we got an unbelievably high increase in TMB.
The MSI score became very high, and the number of frame shifts really
achieved a very high level. But as you can see, it's unbelievably
subclonal.
And this is just another depiction.
We see a large increase in missense mutations, frame shift mutations, tumor
mutational burden gain, and gain in microsatellite instability.
And again, mutational signature.
We see a signature consistent with in the red for mismatch repair
deficiency.
And what was interesting is we were trying to understand why this was happening,
why we were seeing, and what we were seeing is that there's a lot of
methylation in MSH2 promoter,
which induced lack of expression of MSH2,
and we think that that's the mechanism of action.
That's a known mechanism of action with temozolomide, but it's accelerated with the
platinum
significantly.
And the kinetics of this induction, it's interesting because initiallyIf you treat
with temozolomide and cisplatin at week two, you get an increase in MSH2, but then
very rapidly by week four and by week eight, you get a decrease in
MSH2, and there you see a concomitant increase in TMB over time.
And you can see on the bottom the TMB increasing with a variety of different
treatments. But also interestingly, you don't see that shift with
temozolomide alone. You see it by eight weeks in a drop of MSH2 with
temozolomide in the purple, but you don't see an increase in TMB.
So there's something about the combination that was special here.
When we implanted these cells into mice that were
immunocompetent or immunodeficient, in the immunodeficient mice on the right, you
really don't see any difference in growth, but you definitely see a
delayed growth there in the orange of the temozolomide and
cisplatin combined cells that was approximating the MSH2 cell
lines that had previously been created and that were known to be immunogenic and
spontaneously rejected in many mice.
A very delayed growth. You don't see a delayed growth with temozolomide alone.
You don't see a delayed growth with cisplatin, and clearly don't see a delayed
growth with vehicle.
And then when treated with anti-PD-1,
not only was there delayed growth with IgG control, but with anti-PD-1
you see almost a complete abrogation of the tumor,
whereas you don't see that with temozolomide alone or cisplatin alone.
And you see some decrease with MSH2 KO, but not as
good as that treated with
temozolomide and cisplatin.
If we knocked out class one, this was highly dependent on class one expression.
So again, speaking to the mutational
profile that induced one immunogenic response that was highly
dependent on, in this case, CD8 cells.
When we looked at remnant tumors sometimes, we'd take those tumors and sequence
them, and we saw a lot of immunoediting.
And in the team in temozolomide and cisplatin, we saw a
loss of a significant amount of mutations in these tumors
comparing the pre-treatment and the post-treatment tumors that were
injected in mice, the remnant tumor that was left.
And that was classically a loss primarily in frameshift mutations.
So telling us a little bit again about the nature of the mutation that were
lost and immunoedited are most likely frameshifts.
So kind of supporting the hypothesis that these are highly immunogenic because
the immune system in the mouse is removing them.
And then when we looked at the remnant tumor and we wanted to see if there
was persistent mismatch repair, is a remnant tumor maybe
MSS or mismatch repair proficient?
What we saw is even in the remnant tumor that we had persistence
in the signature for mismatch repair deficiency, and we see continued
protein loss. So a genetically stable loss in these
cells even after treatment with PD-1 blockade.
So that was injecting
pre-treated cell lines into mice and looking at the response.
But what about if you injected a tumor in a mouse
and then treated it with temozolomide and cisplatin?
Because that's a real experiment. That's the one we want to do in humans.
So
we wanted to recapitulate something that we would do in humans.
So when we treated with temozolomide and cisplatin alone with IgG or vehicle
control,
we didn't get that much of an improvement with that.
But when we added anti-PD-1 to that, we did get a cure rate in some of these mice
in an intraperitoneal model of an MSS tumor.
And then in terms of toxicity, on the left there I have the
TMB gain with the combination of temozolomide and
cisplatin in cell lines, and you get an increase of
125 mutations per megabase gain. In
normal tissues, in this case in healthy tissues,
and this is bone marrow and lung,
we saw a very small increase in mutations per megabase.
You can see there are less than one mutations per megabase increased.
So a big difference in what's happening in the tumor than what's happening in
normal tissue. Why that difference exists, I don't know.
But there's probably other
DNA repair mechanisms in normal tissue and a lower
division rate that are responsible for that.
Although bone marrow has a higher division rate that approximates many tumors.
And when we looked histologically at where we were seeing loss
of mismatch repair, it was on the cancer cells, and the healthy tissues were
spared in the microenvironment.
So
given that these drugs were used in patients,
we decided to go forward with a clinical trial.
And we did a clinical trial that combined temozolomide,
cisplatin, and PD-1 blockade with nivolumab.
We wanted to ideally first treat with temozolomide and cisplatin, and then later
after we confirmed a higher TMB treat with anti-PD-1, but we wouldn't
have gotten any patients to enroll, and the IRBs were resistant to that.
But what we did see was a general increase in TMB in these patients
and a general increase in the MSI score.
We didn't reach our primary endpoint, which was primarily due to response,
but we did see an induction
pharmacodynamically of a mismatch repair deficiency signature in patients after
treatment.
And what we did was then looked at subgroups of these
patients that we treated. And these were the patients that were treated, are
patients with colorectal cancer that was treatment refractory.
And the patients that did the best and that had the longest survival were those
that not only had a high TMB gain but also had a
gain in mismatch repair deficiency score as measured by circulating tumor DNA.
So while this didn't hit a home run like we
saw in the mice, we've got some
important information here. So where are we going next?
Well, we're going to try to find new inhibitors similar to the ones that
Knyoh4 is using to marry with cisplatin or platinum agents.
We think that you have to lower mismatch repair deficiency and then add
a platinum agent to accelerate the whole process.
And we found a number through an in silico screening methodology where we treated
with 72 hoursWith a variety of different drugs, and we can find drugs
that decrease the expression of MSH2.
We also have a GFP reporter that has a
frameshift mutation that is out of sync or out of line
with the GFP expression. If it induces an insertion or
deletion there that reconstitutes GFP, we can see expression.
And we've already found that a few drugs that recapitulate the loss of mismatch
repair deficiency.
There's also other maneuvers that we can do clinically that I think will be
effective going forward. So I don't think that the failure of the initial clinical
trial is a message that this approach
won't work. I think actually it's a first step showing that it might work.
So in conclusion,
temozolomide and cisplatin induce MMRD genotype
and a phenotype that's immunogenic.
So pharmacologically, we can recreate what we see in patients with
mismatch repair deficiency in the native form,
and it increases sensitivity to PD-1 blockade.
Healthy tissues appear to be spared.
And in the example that Alberto gave on CMMRD, which
are children who are born with loss of both alleles
of a mismatch repair deficient protein, you don't see high TMB in the normal
tissue.
So even though they have replicating normal tissue, you don't
see a high TMB. It's only in the cancer tissue of those patients where you see
higher TMB. So this
and other approaches like the Niafor approach may not induce a higher mutational
burden or injury to normal tissues.
The clinical trial with temozolomide, cisplatin, and PD-1 blockade in
chemo-refractory and mismatch repair deficiency improved overall survival
when patients acquired an MMRD genotype, high TMB,
and mismatch repair deficiency. If you didn't, those patients had a shorter
survival. And we think that this warrants further investigation.
One other thing I'll point out here is it does talk about the
importance of clonality. We're inducing a massively
subclonal tumor,
and even if we just look at experimentally in the mice and the
preclinical models, they're still highly immunogenic.
And so I think that the theory around clonality may be
applicable to one tumor type, but it may not be applicable to
other tumor types like mismatch repair deficiency.
So obviously, I want to thank the sponsors and the families and the patients,
the groups at Johns Hopkins, at Memorial Sloan Kettering,
my lab at Memorial Sloan Kettering,
and a pitch to continue to send great papers to Cancer Discovery.
And thank you very much.
Thank you, Luis. Questions? Yeah.
Hi, Luis.
Yeah.
I just want to ask a question because to reveal my total ignorance of the DNA
repair field. So why do you get lowering of
MSH2 and 6 when you treat with these drugs?
So with temozolomide, actually, with any drugs, and Alberto has shown this
very elegantly,
and others have too, if you treat with a toxic insult, you tend to get an
increase in mismatch repair.
With these drugs and with temozolomide specifically, what we're seeing is
methylation of the promoter for MSH2 and MSH6, and you see a
decrease in expression.
I see.
So-
So that's basically... But that's not a direct effect.
Correct.
I see. Okay.
Great talk. I was wondering because Temodar is very
lymphodepleting, so I was wondering what you saw for the Temodar and
cisplatin, and whether you think that by somehow sparing the
immune cells, maybe you can enhance the response.
So one thing I didn't show you is that we don't want to kill the cancer cells.
We want them to continue to divide. Why?
Because we want them to accumulate mutations.
The goal here with this initial therapy isn't to kill the cancer cell.
It's to allow them to live long enough to accumulate the mutations, so
then when you come with anti-PD-1, you eliminate the tumor.
So we use a much lower dose of temozolomide and a much lower dose of
cisplatin that was non-cytotoxic or an LD10 rather than
LD50 or higher.
Makes sense. Thanks.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you. Great talk. So I was just curious to know whether
the effects that you see when you combine temozolomide and cisplatin in terms of
MSH2 downregulation and increased tumor immunogenicity
can be also recapitulated by using other platinum
derivatives such as carboplatin and oxaliplatin.
This could be relevant because, for instance, carbo is better tolerated by
patients. Oxaliplatin is more effective in other tumor types.
So is this a general mechanism relative to platination? Thank you.
Yeah. I think the general mechanism of inhibiting mismatch repair
and then putting in an insult that will induce frameshift mutations
is a good combination, and it will accelerate what you want.
So if normal-- Let's say you knock out MSH2, it will take nine to 12 months
to induce immunogenicity or a strong one.
This will allow you to accelerate this.
In terms of platinum, there is data that other platinums and other agents will do
this as well.
Thank you.
Yeah.
This is really interesting. I was wondering about the induction
of the mechanisms that you're talking about here.
So with the MSI high tumors, are there
subsets of these tumors that are intrinsically
resistant to MSI high-induced therapy?
And I was wondering about the role of tumor cell intrinsic
genomics in differential
response here to your strategy.
We don't have a good handle on primary resistance
to immune checkpoint blockade in mismatch repair deficient tumors. We don't know.
What's fascinating is about 40% of mismatch repair deficient tumors
have a complete loss of beta 2 microglobulin and don't express class one.
And so even with that, you still get responses.
And
Alberto's lab has shown some of this work. Clinically, this is well-known as well.
And soThat begs the question, what other arms of the immune system are clearing
this?
And so we don't have a very strong handle on this right now.
And whether RAS driven versus PTEN deficient.
So I don't think the classic drivers are driving this one
direction or another. We've seen hints where aneuploidy
may dampen the response, but it's not a complete loss of response.
When we've looked at the curative setting where we completely cure the patient or
in the metastatic setting, we
haven't found good signals there.
Over there.
Yeah, thank you so much. Fantastic talk.
I asked the question in the last session, and they said I should save it for you,
so I'm going to come back and ask again.
In the patients that don't become mismatch repair deficient, and this
kind of ties into maybe the response a little bit, any
idea what might be driving or preventing those
patients from becoming mismatch repair deficient in response?
So if you give temozolomide and cisplatin to a mouse cell line,
it becomes mismatch repair deficient much more easily than human cell lines.
Mm-hmm.
And we have been looking at different intrinsic
pathways of both apoptosis in those cells and what the
drivers are in those cells. And p53 mutant cells appear to be more
difficult to convert into MMRD phenotype or genotype and then phenotype.
But we don't have a clear indication of that.
The other thing is that I do think the division rate of the tumor cell, the basal
division rate, will improve the acquisition of the
phenotype.
Very interesting. One more follow-up question just related to that.
How much do you think the other immunogenic components of
chemotherapy, so induction of
cytosolic DNA sensing, activation of STING, GAS,
maybe increasing MHC type one expression, all of these effects that could happen in
response to chemotherapy. How much do you think that integrates with
converting the tumors into a mismatch repair deficient and ultimately getting a
better response?
So I think that
there's a whole wave of approaches where individuals want to
transiently induce these factors.
And when it's transient,
the tumors will select around that very rapidly.
I think that the strength of this approach is that you're hardwiring the tumors, or
you're selecting or actually inducing mutations
in the tumor cells that are heritable,
that will survive even if a drug disappears or if
the cancer cell becomes resistant to that drug.
And I think that that's very different than, for instance, I think one of the
challenges with targeting the STING pathway or upregulating MHC class
one is there are multiple mechanisms of resistance there.
Fantastic. Thank you so much.
Hello, question maybe for the last two speakers.
So the frequency of MMR deficient tumors, if you look across tumor types, is
very different.
Has there been a link with any type of preexisting immune
microenvironment or things that could explain why in some instances you have
MMR deficient tumors that can develop and in others you don't see them or they
don't appear?
Is this clear or not?
Yeah. So
if you want, that question goes back as to why a tumor becomes
MSI-
Yeah
... to begin with, right? And
it's a question that I continuously challenge our
team to address because it's a fundamental question.
So facts. It seems that
if you look at the normal state or initial stages,
this is not an initial event. It may be occurring slightly later, but
allowing for heterogeneity as to why some tumors
develop that, it's really a fundamental
biological question and why
15% of early stages colorectal tumors are
MSI and not 30%, for me, remains a very good
point.
I don't have really an explanation.
I could elaborate on exposure or genotype or
microbiota, et cetera, but
really, I don't have anything
more intelligent to say. Maybe Luis has.
Certainly not more intelligent, but- ... maybe more confusing.
Why certain
populations have different levels of mismatch repair deficiency is interesting.
In Africa, in Sub-Saharan Africa, the incidence of mismatch repair deficiency is
25% to 30%,
and that's sporadic. It's very different than in
this country, and it's something that's worth investigating.
We know that loss of mismatch repair deficiency in Lynch syndrome,
the likelihood of immunogenicity or the likelihood of
developing tumors is different too.
PMS2 is a less
tumorigenic mutation for mismatch repair deficiency than, let's say,
MSH2, MSH6, MLH1. But when they develop the tumors, they're all
equally as immunogenic.
Okay.
So, there are differences there, but I'm not sure if that answers your question.
No, yeah, it does, but thank you very much. Yes.
All right.
Thank you, Luis. And with that, we conclude this Dharma Master Yen-Tai
Symposium. Thank you all for coming and attending and asking
questions. Thank you.